[Musik]
er wird was klappt jetzt willkommen beim
ein video und zwar steht heute
experiment nummer system und nummer drei
jahren und zwar eigentlich wollte ich
wollte ich das so belasten weil das hat
ja nicht geklappt aber mir hat ein
argument von mir bei snap chat er hat
mich auch eine richtig gute idee
gebracht und zwar so einfach jung alex
täuscht doch mal deine abonnenten mit
drogenkonsum also jetzt nicht so die
krassen drogen sondern die droge gras
oder wie heißt die cannabis nun genau
cannabis ist ja eine illegale droge ist
verboten und da habe ich mir gedacht um
das ja eigentlich auch langweilig meine
bibel mal das rüberbringen
aber ich habe mir zwar richtig kasse
leute überlegt und zwar wenn ich mal ein
ziemlich meinem freund von mir und jetzt
egal wir haben hier auf jeden fall on
paper ja gar nichts vormachen
viele von meinen freunden rauchen und
hier ist auch so nikotin etc und ich
stelle jetzt gleich zwei wirklich sehr
seriöse snaps in meine story die so
rüberkommen als würden die dann nur er
sage ich mal aus versehen gelandet
worden sein oder ihr werdet das gleich
schon sehen und das lasse ich dann
wirklich bis morgen drin wir haben
gerade wo ist mein handy
wir haben ja 20 uhr 21 und ich werde das
erst morgen nach der schule also wenn
ihr alle schule aus habt arbeit vorbei
studium vor bei uns so weiter welche das
erst auflösen und ich bin so gespannt
was ich bis dahin alles bekomme weil es
ungelogen wirklich sehr viel rüber
kommen wird hallo also keine andere
möglichkeit war auf jeden fall wenn ich
jetzt gar nicht lange drumherum
schnappen
ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt gleich
mal die story irgendwann und dann werdet
ihr merken das ist wirklich nicht
schlecht sagt man ja
bis gleich leute also ich hab das jetzt
schon gepostet wir haben eben einfach
mit so einer zigarette so ein zeug hier
gedreht also das ist einfach aber kalt
und es könnte halt auch ein joint sein
also mit cannabis und ich habe jetzt
folgendes nettes nett und ich habe
zeugen des nap chat story und ich kriege
rat auch ungelogen ist schon wieder so
viele nachrichten wartet so leute ich
zeige euch mal kurz meine story
[Musik]
naja das ist gerade meine snapshot dings
also da haben schon sehr viele
geschrieben
in der letzten minute alleine ich bin
richtig gespannt
ich las dass auf jeden fall jetzt bis
morgen drin
ich glaube so bis morgen mittag und dann
bricht die auflösung alter ich kriege
ehrlich so viele nachrichten freuen wir
haben schon 23 18 dieses video wo ich
die anzünder hat schon 18 screenshots
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns dann
morgen und jetzt brauche ich dir erstmal
ruhe alle bauleute wir haben jetzt ich
weiß eben nach hause
glaub so halb eins und ich habe so ultra
viele snap schon bekommen das ist heftig
und ich habe darüber selbst schon leicht
ein schlechtes gewissen so weil ich mir
auch so denkt okay war das jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen dumm dass zu
machen
immerhin das ist jetzt ja da für zwölf
stunden drin sah ich mal und in der zeit
so kleinere kinder die wissen ja nicht
ob das spaß ist oder ob er alex das
ernst meinen ja deswegen ist das jetzt
natürlich blöd und ich habe auch
wirklich schon sehr sehr viele
nachrichten bekommen
das denn sollen ob ich dunkeln und so
was halt aber gut na ja ich öffne morgen
macht den großteil über viele snacks und
schneit so das krasseste zusammen zeigt
euch auch ein paar whatsapp nachrichten
aber ich musste mich erstmal natürlich
jetzt aufs autofahren konzentrieren ganz
wichtig ist erstmal schlafen wir sehen
uns gleich wieder rein wie heute da bin
ich schon wieder ich weiß es war
eigentlich nur zwei sekunden für euch
aber für mich war es eine ganze nacht ja
also ich bin immer aufgestanden und hat
mal geguckt was da abgeht ich habe das
ein bisschen abgeschätzt also ich müsste
auf dieses experiment bezogen bestimmt
zwischen 600 und 1000 snacks bekommen
haben die sich nur darauf beziehen also
echt so heftig war es wirklich noch nie
selbst wenn ich sage ja auch schnell
wieder fragen krieg vielleicht so 300
oder so aber das war echt krass was
jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen scheiße ist
dann habe ich gestern gar nicht gedacht
also die selbst von heute die sehe ich
alle aber die die schon so jahrzehnten
schon zurückliegen die sind halt
irgendwie also bilder kann ich nicht
mehr angucken und videos erst rechtlich
halten nur wenn irgendwer wie ein chat
geschickt hat aber gut da sind auch echt
harte sachen aber also das sind richtig
harte knochen die ich da zum teil lesen
musste dass mich leute deponieren wollen
dass sie mich scheiße finden selbst wenn
es nur ein spaß ist also die story hat
gerade einfach 611 screenshots und über
nacht und heute morgen ich meinen die
meisten sind gerade in der schule das
haben nicht mal das haben nicht mal der
hälfte von leuten die ich aufs deutsche
abgesehen so und bevor wir zu den snap
kommen wollte ich erst mal ein paar
reaktionen auf what's up zeigen und zwar
mich gestern echt sehr sehr viele leute
angeschrieben wo ich zum teil nicht mal
wusste dass die meine nummer haben ich
habe zum beispiel diese nachricht
bekommen oder zum beispiel diese
nachricht löst das mal bitte wir gucken
viele kleine kinder zu so leute und
jetzt kommen wir zu den ganzen
nachrichten die ich gestern abend von
euch doch bekommen habe wo ich will zum
teil dachte
letztes mal hat irgendwie kein gejuckt
aber diesmal echt viele also wirklich
sehr sehr viele erstmal danke dafür ich
finde die reaktion gut dass viele von
euch direkt zu sagen ja alex das geld
nicht bis zu dumm warum machte den so
ich würde sagen ich lese einfach mal ein
paar vor und blend die dann hier neben
ein zb diesen
recht es ist ja noch okay wenn typisch
aber nimmt sp droge mini kollege
kollegin ich strebe gestorben das tut
mir natürlich leid und nein ich nehme
keine drogen
da hat man sollte man die finger lassen
oder zum beispiel diese nachricht ach du
heilige scheiße
sag mal spinnst du aus lust und laune
einfach zu kippen
da macht man nicht so einfach sei das
was bringt dir das über entspannen oder
einfach mal was ist schiefgelaufen alter
falter dann habe ich auch einige
aufmunternde nachrichten bekommen zum
beispiel von der emily warum herz
letzteres so perfekt aber warum machst
du das das ist nicht gut aber hab dich
lieb
danke dass ich auch mal kurz dazu sagen
muss ich meinen dieses andere experiment
von mir wo ich alkohol getrunken habt
das ist vielleicht eineinhalb wochen her
so und viele haben auch gecheckt dass
das einfach nur ein dritter part von
sowas ist aber vielleicht auch nicht so
dann habe ich euch heute noch dazu
aufgerufen mir doch einfach mal zu
schicken ob ihr dachte das ist real oder
nichts
ich dachte ja das war raus du das meinst
hören hab ich mir gedacht alter jetzt
geerntet also ich hab das ich geglaubt
weil deine reaktion war sehr auffällig
und ja durch die anderen beiden videos
weil er klar was du sowas nicht machen
wird ist also wäre es jetzt nicht das
dritte mal gewesen dann hätte man
vielleicht noch abkaufen können aber
erst gegenseitig werden
alles klar also sie hat es geglaubt
[Musik]
alles klar danke ja aber das war jetzt
einige reaktionen fand ich wirklich zum
teil sehr gut und habe mich gefreut dass
die reaktion diesmal auch wirklich kamen
und nicht so wie beim letzten mal das
war jetzt auch das letzte mal von mir
verstört versprochen da gibt es nicht
mehr was ich dachte nur die idee wer
cool und eigentlich war ganz cool glaube
ich ich habe das video hat euch ein
bisschen gefallen falls ja fast nur noch
um da würde mich sehr freuen
ich sag mal so wenn wir 15.000 likes
waffen mache ich das nicht nochmal
checkt auf jeden fall meinen snapshot ab
hier mal kurz eingeblendet wir sehen uns
dann ja ich glaube am samstag wieder am
ersten weihnachtstag kommt ein richtig
cooles video auch ein experiment aber
ein bisschen mit andere ist lässt sich
kostenlos zu abonnieren ist allrad ist
bei mir ja ich bin der einzige youtube
in dem man auch kostenlos abonnieren
kann deswegen macht es auf jeden fall
wir sind ein